Oh No
there's a picture of my penis on TMZ
again that's the fourth time this week
oh well I guess there's nothing I can do
about it
wait I can help who are you
I'm with the junk squad we teach
congressmen who weren't born in the
digital age how to send pictures of
their penis safely and discreetly Wow if
you're old enough to find computers
perplexing one of our junk squad
technicians will personally visit your
home office or governor's mansion and
safely guide you through the process
from start to finish
sounds great first of all as a
high-ranking public figure are you sure
you want to send someone you barely know
a picture of your penis absolutely it
has to be done okay let's do it right
we provide expertise in every area of
secure penis photograph transmission I
want to put this into this so you need
to run for public office and send out
blurry photos of your disembodied penis
call the junk squad we even offer 24
hour on call emergency services yeah
yeah yeah junk squad I think I did
something wrong
junk squad customers must be over 35
running for public office and born
without shame
[Applause]